back welcome back everyone to gamespot
cross kind of funny i'm your host greg
miller alongside the one and only Scott
Porter now stop clapping Scott Porter
Scott Porter is a new dad now really
there you go congratulations three weeks
in two days was it going it's going good
here are you sleeping a little bit yeah
he'll do like patches of like four hours
at a time at night so we've gotten to
that stage at least ice three hours to
sleep wake up another three hours of
sleep and then go are you able to play
games anymore um yeah cuz he's like he
has no motor skills so I just lay him on
my chest and I just I just raid and
stuff with him so that's the one thing
about you Scott Porter is that you're
one of these guys who's too good-looking
you're too talented but then I love you
even more because you're into video
games like really really into video game
I'm better at games than I am at any of
those other things not true i saw i saw
that albury movie you were in shirts off
here with the lifeguard you were great
in it you kept me come up yeah so what
are you playing right now um I mean
pretty much it's just easy for me to get
on destiny yeah I play like you know 30
40 minutes a day The Witcher I've
started to play the witcher but it's
like those missions are so long yeah
that if he needs to be my new son if you
need to be changed or fed in any way I
just I've got to stop in the middle of a
mission oh my gosh that's young kid it's
not how I like to do it i know you own
everything all my son is just getting in
the way of all my gaming Yeah right wait
where does he get off i'm trying to be
so needy just get a job get out of the
house come on kid pull your weight so
what I want to know is I feel like
you're one of those guys who kind of
lives the dream of so many of us where
you love games you play games and then
now you start you've been working in
games yeah you were Luke in the walking
dead yes Superboy lego batman and uncle
man and not one nobody cares about him
it's awesome right come on everybody
loves soccer and then now you're
Nightwing yes we can Batman Arkham
Knight yes that I still haven't even
seen anything there over there i know
i'll go over there okay sure who i am
very much now dual play do something ya
know I was you know what man the crazy
thing about doing Batman was being like
watching the animated series for so long
yeah
the first moment I went into the booth I
put the head and they already had
recorded you Kevin so of a sudden
Conroy's lying to me nightwing I need
you to go look at this thing and I was
like ah I need to go change my pants I
just crapped myself his voice is so
awesome and iconic and then like to work
against it was uh it was insane so I
mean like how did you make that
transition because you started as like
screen actor right how I made the
transition was by coming to e3 getting
into like a back room and being like oh
I love your games I was in front of my
life I have I would like to be in your
games and literally like with telltale
with the walking dead yeah it was a
recast thing and they tweeted me the
night before and they're like okay we
think we finally have something for you
would you be willing to be a part of the
next Walking Dead game and I was like
yes on Twitter I confirmed that I love
doing that yes on twitter i will do your
game yes and and that was that was that
man cuz i had told them for years gone
in and just let him know that i was a
fan of their games all I'm saying it's a
great way to do it and that's what we
should all do from now and when we meet
developers let him know like they're
here so we would all love to be in their
game that's an easy way to do it that's
I mean everybody's path is different but
yeah so did that start the ball rolling
then so we're like Emmy it's one of
those things when I walk around III I
get stopped a lot when I'm with you you
get stopped a lot too and it's like
everybody just knows you cuz your video
game I'm always surprised when i get
stopped here because you know it video
games are such an entertainment thing in
their own right and a lot of people that
i know that game don't also watch TV
yeah are you know they don't watch as
many films as you would because they're
always gaming that's that's their
entertainment experience so I'm always
surprised that there's a bigger
cross-section of fans for TV and video
games should I thought so so then which
do you like more do you like to being in
front of the camera you do Heart of
Dixie obviously for a while there and
like do you get a game it's really i
mean the consistency of television is
fantastic yeah but the amount of hours
you have to work out a game is so so
small yeah like you know i just started
a new project last week and did my first
session it was for like a large chunk of
the game and i was only there for like
four hours and it's just you go in you
have all your cues in front of you
deliver line after line and then
you're right you're out you're gonna
have their you can have a life when I'm
doing TV i'm at work for 14 hours a day
with an xbox in a playstation in my
trailer so I can pretty game not a bad
way to be on the downtime so so then
what's next I are you what are you gonna
be in whats the next game for you you me
another game what's need to reveal
something oh man I might possibly be a
part of another telltale Game coming up
they have a lot of those tests the
problem with tells how is they have too
many games you can't narrow it down yeah
i mean it's it's an awesome project the
cast is insane like when they ask me a
big part of it and they're like these
are the other people were looking at and
these the other people who are working
on the game I mean there's people you
love from film and television and huge
iconic game voices too so there's like
they're all over the place so I can't I
can't I can't tell you you're right
everyone's favorite no one's gonna get
things called in d800 as you sign up
nobody everything I got after you know
I'd rather not get sued oh now now that
you have the little one yeah you want to
be around more i'm assuming do you see
your do you want to think transition
more towards voice work I mean you know
what it's I have been so fortunate to do
a little bit of everything it started
out doing Broadway and off-broadway so
I've done theatre I've done some movies
like you know and television and I just
want to keep it all like rolling
together man there's this been this
wonderful like synergy between
everything I would like to work on some
larger more iconic games that I played
forever sure I would kill to be a part
of Halo or you know or work with bungie
on destiny you know going forward you
know companies that I you know or square
like if there's there's any way I could
be part of a final fantasy game I made
of a new final fantasy 7 they gotta have
to put some voices and I know I know and
I think I could I could probably pull
out he seems like a no-brainer you're a
huge destiny now how many hours destiny
do you have currently 840 hours 840 hour
I have a 34 warlock at 34 titan and a
3400 that seems like i know about doing
eagle us and i've been to the lighthouse
on Mercury so let's let's just put it
all in there do you know this deej fella
I don't know this DG personally we're in
a sweet deeds right now I will say hey
agent bungee scott porter needs to be a
destiny let
and everyone out there will retweet it
now spoiler alert there's an hour tape
delay so go through my tweets yeah okay
an hour an hour okay you tell us you
tell a cute story about destiny right
now a cute story yeah okay Mike Gallo
horn how i received my gala horn sure it
was the second exotic I ever got I had a
legendary in in Graham drop a heavy
weapon and Graham I took it to the Crypt
arc and everybody hated that guy sucks
and master Rahul just was like I like
you here was a gala horn and night and
that's how i got my gala horn it's not a
cute story it's actually a story that
pissed everybody off that's watching you
know who gets really madam boys had a
voice from hi Joe struggling to get
there and I was over there today I got
some hands-on with the new classes how I
think my yeah I'd the Stormbreaker or
whatever the Warlock new classes oh it
was awesome and the guy that I was
playing with actually on the team on the
dev team for destiny yea big a lemorian
did you do the whole thing I oh yeah
what I loaded me in your game I'd well
Nova see the unfortunately there wasn't
the people that I could I could tell to
like get me in the game like there they
weren't there so I will hopefully at
some point I like that you're tweeting
deej right now hey deej and bungee Scott
Porter wants to be in destiny the game
he is all level 30 fours let's do it
yeah all right like to be a voice I
would love to do some future super
future DLC that girl that's the eris
more and I just here in my sleep every
crew till like I could probably I want
to know is like when you showed up and
we started talking you showed me a
little destiny card you got your shader
and stuff like that I got away don't
show the code don't show the code you
idiot I got my gosh there with Scott
right already this is on an hour tape
delay i've been better open up your
place boy I've already redeemed this
code don't try and use this code I'm
very [ __ ] over that mass station
network Africa cracking on that I prove
it nobody less thing went for this
shader blacksmith [ __ ] was going for
three hundred fifteen dollars for a
digital gold for a shader on eBay that's
been insane that's how much people love
this games mine now sears now hopefully
yeah now here's the thing is like yeah
you can you up in your show it in your
oxide and I'm like all right forget
sometimes I forget your the big destiny
guy I was like you gotta meet alfredo
and then alfredo walked in the booth and
you guys are best pic as thieves you
already know each other I did I was like
oh of course everyone else got Porter
first time I beat Croatoan hard was with
Fredo
Fredo and Buddy this kid over here free
should be afraid oh it was just amazed
morning where Fredo likes to be on skype
with everybody else the other side of
the Sun isn't it Fredo likes to be on
skype and ever not everybody else has
skype yeah so have like two thirds of
the team or on other skype two thirds or
game chat and then one do doesn't even
have a mic and somehow we still be crota
on hard which I was like so how did you
find out about Alfredo Diaz the king of
twitch and also the king of destiny I
actually met him in san fran in person
yeah even get a table of swag and i was
like what is all this swag for he was
like is that is that hero click I was
like yeah it is we both play heroclix
that'll do it every time was this what
an IGN yeah when he came through for
tells him yes I like this and then from
then on best of your enemies best of
friends yeah I guess still got to run
you through trials yeah yeah it
shouldn't surprise me you're both
beautiful get two beautiful amazing
looking man who just love destiny and
growing out there yeah so then so you're
all in then on taking king oh I am all
ain't well you know the thing is is so
I'm starting to get a little upset
because I was like ah PVE you don't get
a good primary from PVE only can get
them in pvp I was like you know what
alright destiny all right I put so many
hours in your game done officially done
no no I don't send that to try to break
up with destiny a number of times yeah
it's like that Taylor Swift song it's
like try to break up it sounds like yeah
the tailor sews are never getting back
together or removal you're saying I'm
not talkin [ __ ] about destiny you ain't
gonna be talking [ __ ] but I tried to
quit a number of times and I was like I
was officially going to quit yeah i got
all my characters to 34 I was like
there's nothing else for me to do except
for you know maybe get back to go to the
lighthouse a mercury and that's it and
you know once that's done I'm like I'm
done I'm done and then they drop this
the jumpsuit bomb of the Kazon September
we're not too far away from that I know
I never playing another game again yeah
that's the problem you asked me earlier
if I was still playing because I have a
kid yeah taylor swift i duel of destiny
but i have to be that guy who's like i
love destiny but I've only put like 24
hours into a 23 hours into enemy and a
half of that was just getting your
picture get my character oh yeah watch
good
any other part of the ass but I'll at it
but I took that I took one of those
weekends off wherever he's into it I
left and I came back and people would
jump so far ahead that was hard to get
it going it wasn't the same thing and
now it's just I feel so far behind get
on with us and we'll get you your you're
fine but it's so much easier to level up
now that they've updated the game but
the problem is is though it will become
them though only came out I have to play
but I stuff to play with your it's
Batman next week then it's metal gear
then it's fallout it's like do I really
have time you fit it in oh I mean once
it comes out who has time yes again
right but then he just walks out maybe
an hour to jump on do your night falls
or we leave no I've you if we set up an
hour every night I'll come on in today
you'll be a Tuesday gamer jump on after
the result do all your stuff and then
jump back up jump right back on
character and we'll get you up to 34 and
it'll be like that oh yeah yeah I mean I
did start playing The Witcher though man
Witcher is so involved which is awesome
oh it's so awesome that was us
confirming an hour every night of
playing down yes I mean I'm gonna trust
you in the in the division now yeah now
division with you and I are locked in we
are locked our you want to join our
division road when did this happen when
we watch when we finish our we've been
down the kind of our we wait how long
are we convinced that the division is
ever coming out still when it comes what
it does in the deal we squats again
we're gonna squad together and ideals
the squad will never turn on each other
here here we go here we go well except
for I mean we didn't agree on with with
Colin no rogue agent stuff no let's not
go rope let's not say no room yes that
that thing at the end was it my soul was
a gamer oh we won't do that and hurt but
are we convince that is coming out I i
think wednesday i even thinking I think
we'll see the division for a fourth year
at e3 next year anybody want to put odds
on that or anything that's highly I
don't think it's highly possible yeah
you think it's gonna make it out before
then you know you know so get some I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say it will come out
before next ether oh right now to pep up
put 20 on it that's a bit all right
right there late on gentlemen that's
Alfredo that Scott Porter we all love
destiny go support Scott Porter on
twitter and go plays games he's in
Batman next week yes here's more
gamespot cross kind of funny